you know it's actually crazy stat about
the oxytocin thing this is this blew my
mind so I'm just curious what do you
think the average body count is let's
say for a 31 year old in the UK
what do you think body count average
because that's that's the average age of
first marriage woman woman sorry for a
woman
that you um say they start having sex at
16. I would say what they would want to
say would be nine is probably more
realistically
25 plus 25 plus okay what do you think
yeah I'd say 20 20. I'll stay with 25 I
don't know 25. I don't know I do you
have dear friends I do but like how how
old are you are you ready yeah I'm 31.
okay so how like friends around your age
would you say ballpark most of them are
like in Long terms marriages like
okay so so when they got married what
would you guess you don't have to four
five four five that I know okay four or
five
um so crazy thing is that when you have
are a virgin and you're married you you
have an 80 chance of a happy marriage
after 10 years
what do you think that drops down to
when you've had sex with more than five
people
[Music]
ten
five
five
oh actually guessed low no it's it's
like 20 25 so it goes from an 80 chance
to a 25 chance of a happy marriage in 10
years
I wanted to ask something you know when
you were like what would you advise your
daughters yeah do you think that women
let's say who've been like sexually
active can at some point stop and then
decide well when I get married or is it
just not the same so I think they can
stop but I think like God God can
forgive you but men don't that's true so
so it's like you're a used product and
oftentimes like if you come to a guy and
say Here's the new price for me they're
like yeah [ __ ] that I'm gonna just go
find the next 22 year old that's
available so I mean what I see in the
churches is I see it's like when girls
do
this is what I see
I see a girl that's like you know maybe
six to eight level if I had like one to
ten yeah she's she's cute right dude
like a five right she she got ran
through before and she's like you know
what I need to get married this is this
is this is going south I can't do this
anymore so she says all right this is my
new pricing
and it's always the guy that's like one
to two levels below her that buys
like like just slightly less good
looking kind of like not there and so
it's like these beta dudes like that
that are buying because it's like a guy
that's like actually masculine he's not
gonna yeah compromise but but like you
know in a way
I mean do they deserve each other I
don't know yeah as long as they're happy
yeah but I just but I don't think the
girls really respect their husbands a
lot because it goes back to the alpha
Widow thing they really want the guys
before so I don't I don't know what the
solution is that's just what I see
because when I saw this in the church I
couldn't unsee it roll it to mossi
ruined church for me forever forever
because everything in the church is like
gynocentrics it's all about the woman
because even in the language it's always
like like in in I had Chastity speakers
I went to Catholic school and they give
us Chastity speakers and it was always
the girl talking about how broken she
was what the [ __ ] you weren't broken you
were horny let's take some
accountability let's take some
accountability for this like I'm tired
and so like even I was like why do the
men and the men give her a microphone
nothing so it's like all women's center
oh my God I couldn't unsee it and like
it's like basically a mating strategy
because like girls usually find God
around like 27 to 30. so it's like after
their party phase and so it doesn't seem
genuine to guys because they're like oh
that's convenient right when time's
running out so yes they're converting
and they're coming to them and saying
here new pricing and they're like ah and
I I could not unsee this yeah this is
coming from someone I've always like 12
years in Catholic school I I yeah
I couldn't see it I also I always think
the answer to those kind of situations
of the bait are getting with you know a
woman with a with a past like that is
the man rediscovering his like
masculinity red pill because I think you
know at some point you can't avoid those
kind of conclusions it happens but if
you're masculine self-possessed I think
you can manage it as best you can I
think when the man is feminine and is
still beta then she doesn't respect him
and then it you know she she gets a
divorce and then goes from divorce to
divorce I can't lie by then it's too
late but then it's too late he he's
already he's in it too deep yeah he
can't then find uh the red pill figure
it out and go okay like oh yeah like I I
now know how to be a man she's looked at
him as a as a beta yeah
I didn't say it will be easy he's gonna
have to do it for like two years before
she recognizes that all right maybe this
guy's growing a bit I don't think girls
like once we see you in a certain way I
don't think it changes like we always
kind of yeah like it's kind of like how
the frick is Steph Curry's wife
like how the [ __ ] is is she wanting
attention from other guys when you're
married to Steph Curry
I mean Steph I'm trying to get some
tickets but
it's like do you know what I'm saying so
it's because she got him when she was
like above him in sexual market value
even though he's Sir Patrick that's
still how she sees him it's the same
thing with Will and Jada Jada's like
what a five a four no one's lining up to
date 50 year olds like she looks good
for her age someone made an 18 minute
video about how ugly I was because I
said Jaden was a five that was too far
too far I saw it I saw it
yeah the audacity so don't don't make
another okay I've seen it anyways but
like like it's because she back then
they were kind of on the same level and
even though he's surpassed him as a
world super far sorry she still treats
him like [ __ ] it's like the alpha Widow
thing because she really wanted the
tupacs she didn't want well he's like
anyway like how how disrespectful she
did Next Level Will Smith is not
stepping up as a man
so what I'm saying is I think there's
always a respectable honorable way to
deal with any situation you find
yourself I don't think he can change
um his situation because Jada views him
in a certain way whether he wants to be
a man in any way shape or form it would
have mattered it's already done so
you've got man to do a writing letters
to Tupac
what he could leave he could he could
open somewhere
it's a business in exchange Mutual
exchange I would I would still dump Jeff
Bezos had the same thing right Jeff you
know clearly cheated on his wife with
someone from Amazon she was like listen
you know I I I'm entitled to like half
of the billions you've got and he was
like yeah take it bro yeah he made that
back has balls in it that's what I'm not
saying it can be pretty sometimes you
have to hold it out on it like listen
this is you know your girl was about but
you can still deal with it like a
respectable man I think like it's going
to be hard but you can no I I agree with
you like there's some accountability I
heard TLA talk about though
What Will Smith's like dating options
are like and he's like you know what
from that guy's point of view it's like
you're just old and you're tired and
yeah you could go have the 20 year old
25 like the hot maybe 31 year old
whatever you want but he's like
then you they're going to be with their
phones and their face all the time I
don't know I wish I'm not I'm not
articulating it right but if you guys
ever watch TLA like bleed attorney he is
the funniest bit on this just talking
about why Will Smith is gonna stay
indoors he is at this point yeah but I
think he's actually bought her spiritual
gibberish like I think he when she says
behind the scenes
generally he's like yeah healing like he
has a round table talk to going out his
like personal family business yeah I
really thinks he's winning no he thinks
he's been the a bigger Man by airing out
all this stuff yo he's he's in the
shadow round bro oh my gosh you think he
just loves her he's just oh yeah no he
definitely no he loves her but that's
blindly yeah that's weak love bro I I
called this before anything happened
they were the power couple everyone
loved them yeah and I said no
something's wrong look at their kids no
no I said I said this I said this before
anyone else did I'm like Mom Dad I grew
up in a stable two-parent home you guys
were great parents none of us are on
that weird [ __ ] there's 10 of us you
adopted three teenagers they my parents
adopted three teenagers they didn't even
raise them most of their life and they
didn't turn out like that it's like why
why is Willow or whatever wanting to be
in an open relationship and talking
about this on red table talk this is
before this is when they were the power
couple and I'm like we're not on that
weird [ __ ] and you see the grandma on
the show she's like what have I done
she was coming
yeah from and that like there are kids
they were talking about how they had
this bad choice in life and that every
time they were complaining Will Smith it
was like it was him his fault we've been
living in his shadow because he's a like
very famous man so it was forcing us to
be the actress
yeah Jade is famous too they were
probably talking to Jada like there's no
one there
is not as famous as Jay but she's still
Beyonce though yeah
Jayden would be nobody if it wasn't for
will yeah yeah
she's known as Will's wife exactly yeah
because she's pretty bro I have to rest
my case on a Beyonce comparison yeah
like Beyonce was a world Superstar since
she was six nice facts all right cool
you're gonna move in your room
no I forgot I called this years ago and
then when all this stuff came out I
called my mom because my mom I I told
her that she's like no no not will
there's not weird stuff going on and I
called her and I was like I told you
anyways um Mom if you're watching this
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible